le résultat final ne faisait aucun doute
et donc pour la troisième fois dans
l'histoire des états unis
et sans grande surprise un président
américain est acquitté des accusations
qui pesait contre lui sur les deux
articles de destitution donald trump est
donc déclarée non coupable
seule consolation pour les démocrates
qui ont donc perdu leur pari le sénateur
républicain mitt romney a déclaré donald
trump coupable d'abus de pouvoir
la gorge nouée my faith
ma foi est au coeur de ce que je suis
dit ils jugé le président chef de mon
propre parti fut la décision la plus
difficile de ma vie
donald trump réagira demain midi depuis
la maison blanche pour parler de ce
qu'il appelle sa grande victoire sur ce
canular l'insee g un des plus fidèles
alliés du président estime que cet
acquittement pave la voie à la
réélection du président en novembre
prochain
anyway et le chef de la majorité
républicaine au sénat met en garde ses
adversaires dans 2 2 ne vous avisez pas
de recommencer ce genre de procédures et
aux coûts et les motards pacte trump a
été acquitté sans un procès équitable
avec un verdict qui n'a aucune valeur
selon le sénateur démocrate ben bradshaw
c'est donc la fin d'une procédure
amorcée il ya quelques mois par le parti
démocrate
en faisant défiler leurs témoins pendant
plusieurs semaines les adversaires de
donald trump avait bâti une plaidoirie
pour le destituer abus de pouvoir et
entrave au travail du congrès dans
l'affairé craignent n était donc les
deux chefs d'accusation choisi
les accusations qui selon eux était
matière à destitution tel que défini
dans la constitution américaine
les témoignages à charge de diplomates
et d'experts avait beau être solide
selon les démocrates la défense
républicaine les a minimisés les
qualifiant de lui dire et de preuves
circonstancielles et puis la maison
blanche avait aussi mis son grain de
sable dans l'engrenage démocrates en
empêchant la comparution de témoins clef
citant la confidentialité des liens
présidentielle
l'acquittement prévisible d'aujourd'hui
est un coup dur pour les démocrates
qu'importe d'ainsi pelosi l'a rappelé
maintes et maintes fois dans les livres
d'histoire dit-elle donald trump a été
destitué par la chambre du congrès et il
ne peut rien y faire
[Applaudissements]